hey my brother hello AG oh you bend over
for me already
y'all ready let me go it's my turn to
eat huh okay uh oh oh oh no no no no
I'm out of here son of the [ __ ] I mean
there we always do these voices every
state money okay just call my mother
where did you come mama no hey where is
she not again every time yeah man look
at that big face they're so happy the
happy family
I'm going to kill you I remember the
painting but I don't remember anything
oh my big oh my god Rekha nobody messes
with the best the best family were you
going oh hey that's sunglasses thanks
pretty cool yes so cool yeah man oh my
god my mother Mia ah Tony Hawk in it I
jumped at me huh yeah
through a 360 360 no shell she but with
the shell you look at this so cool ah
Mario on sigh backflip I'm so
disappointed I pick it up here I don't
know I don't think we'll just be here
now I can do watch me hey you could do a
Luigi I can do it ah why are your
nipples are very brutal on my with a
fish go [ __ ] the fish oh we can go there
okay let's go thank ya oh we need
something here okay no no careful buddy
oh oh mama the media oh mama the Meade
mama the beer I'm Becky my knee
ah ah [ __ ] would you are you my hair you
will not believe this Luigi don't tell
me hey yes I lasted my wedding ring hey
do it again that's why I think about
your it Mamma Mia
must be stupid that was there was I've
ever smelled
oh my God we're pig oh you looking so
can you ah what a little peach hit what
a little tiny petite the beach I love
this sound you make Oh hilarious the
fire oh wait oh go that way Louise yeah
mama the Mia oh hi lanius
whoa whoa whoa how do you do that oh
these moves yeah show me the breakdance
moves Mario what have you learned these
Wow yeah
okay we did it
what's over here oh god oh god oh god oh
god
Thank You Angie okay okay I'm gonna Mia
Mamma Jesse just one coin you forget the
killing me
I got a hurry other bag Mario Luigi you
are my only star
this box down here he's like yeah yeah
oh my god oh my god oh my god I got huh
my musket oh my back hey Luigi I'm
Sandra I'm sister of your wedding ring
it will give us gay hey hey hey Kavitha
down did we kill her that look bad you
think you can just walk up to me like
that I'm scared Mario raging [ __ ]
scared me I'm out again [ __ ] this
catch a [ __ ] Oh Luigi that was the bomb
ha ha ha ha ha
can we [ __ ] scale I don't know Louise
me my dad there we go oh but I do
hold on that but he uh I can't look for
you my wife I miss you is this your wife
no another clock buzzer why you wouldn't
know like my marriage why you know let
me be happy it's because Bowser's a
dragon right they have him is a dragon
Luigi I forget about your fire fight
your daily life blah oh oh it's already
which I can show you the way all of the
spaghetti and meatballs
hilarious ID but that we that's what
happened if you don't look for your
wedding movie long jump Luigi Yahoo I'm
skin Oh MLG oh these skills you would
you must tell you something what what I
think I think Bowser
but is cheating on you with beach I
think what say it say it Mario
I think Bowser's pregnant mama I lost my
way they don't believe it it is a little
pepper
y'all gonna kill her I'm gonna [ __ ]
the [ __ ] in the hopper episodes for my
money I don't know Tennessee I'm gonna
[ __ ] kill you